imagine a world where you're not even
human you can create universes with ease
and control
time this could be a reality in an
incredibly Advanced and I mean an
incredibly Advanced
civilization okay we've talked about
what if Humanity reaches type 1 through
type five civilizations but what if we
take it a step further what if we become
a type 6 or seven
civilization What would life be like
then is a type 7 civilization even
possible what would humans look like and
why might something like this be a
terribly bad
idea this is what if and here's what
would happen if Humanity became a type
seven
civilization okay before we start let's
quickly read recap the types of
civilizations we've covered so far I'll
make it
quick type one civilization okay here
Humanity gains control of Earth and
we're able to access all the power on
the planet type two civilization well
this is where we harness the power of
the Sun and start to populate other
planets like Mars and Venus type three
Civilization now humanity is controlling
the entire galaxy commanding the power
of black holes multiple stars and all
other celestial
bodies these civilizations were
conceived by Nikolai kardashev who
created the kardashev scale it's a
hypothetical framework used to measure a
civilization's ability to harness
technological power civilizations 1 to
three were developed by kardashev
himself but the list has since expanded
in a more speculative manner to add
types 4 through 7 here are some of of
them in Fast Forward type four
civilization well Humanity gains the
ability to populate and control the
entire
universe type five Civilization now
humanity is controlling multiple
universes we've become a multiversal
civilization so that's 1 through five
but what happens next is pretty
ridiculous and we should preface that
this goes beyond the expanded cev
making these next civilizations purely
speculative they're also getting so
Advanced that scientists claim these
civilizations are hard to even
comprehend we'll be dealing with
problems we don't even know about yet
but hey you guys asked for this so let's
strap in things are about to get
weird now during our journey to a type
seven civilization climate change could
seriously affect the Earth especially if
we don't do anything to stop it but
don't worry there's hope did you know
that renewable energy is getting cheaper
every year yeah and countries are
investing more resources into it than
ever before the Environmental Group
American climate Corps announced a new
program that's going to train 20,000
people in clean energy and climate
resilience this is only the start and
should help us progress even more into a
future with renewable energy let's try
to keep the momentum going remember you
can push your leaders and neighbors for
change and make a huge impact on the
environment now let's check in on our
next
civilization type 6
civilization a type 6 civilization will
see some significant upgrades from our
type five
civilization instead of controlling
parts of multiple universes well we can
now control
everything yeah we can instantly create
or destroy any Universe of our choosing
not only that but time would become a
new toy for us to play with we can now
manipulate it any way we want feel free
to create multiple timelines maybe I'll
create one where I'm the president or I
have blonde hair or maybe one where I'm
super
jacked and with all these multiverses
Humanity wouldn't be the only
Civilization by now there's a good
chance that we've discovered or even
created multiple civilizations of other
new species across different universes
ones that range from type zero to type
5 and of course with us at the top of
the food chain Humanity would be the
rulers of these
civilizations or we might view them as
cultures that are lesser than us maybe
we'll just observe them in the same way
we do with ant colonies or zoo animals
and what would you look like if in a
type 6 civilization well definitely not
like you do now or I guess you could if
you wanted to let me show you some
examples you'd have the power to control
reality and matter so if you wanted you
could look like you do now or you could
look like the rock there's also a chance
that we would no longer be biological
beings as we've progressed through these
civilizations technology and AI have
only been getting more advanced
we may have fused with artificial
intelligence becoming Robo human
hybrids maybe we'd look like
this and if you're more creative who
knows what you could be you could be an
alien a Godlike giant or go a more
efficient route and become a ball of
energy one that could move around
universes with ease now if you think a
type 6 civilization sounds nuts well
wait till you see what's
next type seven
civilization as we progress through
these civilizations things are only
getting more ridiculous weird and
confusing we're now officially at the
point where this civilization is almost
Beyond human
comprehension we'd have the ability to
create alter and Destroy more
universes
ultimately controlling everything one of
the key differences between a type six
and seven civilization would be us being
able to control the
Omniverse okay again this is entirely
speculative but the Omniverse is even
bigger than the
Multiverse it contains an infinite
amount of universes both real and
fictional it shows every conceivable
timeline and contains realities we can't
even understand
yet humans or whatever we're called at
this point would be able to transcend
any form of physical or metaphysical
reality our new forms are
unimaginable at least with our current
knowledge we'd be past the point of
having to worry about dying or any form
of suffering instead humans might exist
in a state of constant Bliss
Enlightenment and Euphoria we we might
be able to exist simultaneously in
multiple realities and timelines able to
see everything in the past present and
future with all this incredible power it
kind of begs the question would Humanity
even want to get to this
point would we even be considered human
I mean Society has progressed so far
that we're not even experiencing the
things that make us who we are instead
of hanging out with our loved ones and
following our passions we're now
Invincible beings who have transcended
our current feeble human needs and ideas
we're building new realities and playing
God we'd also have plenty of existential
challenges in this period with Humanity
being so powerful and controlling
everything well what would there be for
us to do we've already conquered the
Earth the universe and now the
Omniverse where does Humanity progress
and what would we have left to
accomplish we wouldn't experience any
adversity or challenges two essential
aspects of our human life so as exciting
as these things sound would it be worth
it maybe we should go back and
experience what life would be like if
Humanity turned into a type one
civilization that might be more
manageable and
realistic and it also sounds like a
story for
another what
if